let's talk about the foods that you
definitely need to avoid if you have a
thyroid problem specifically a
hypothyroid condition and so the biggest
thing that you need to be aware of are
these things called goitrogens now what
is a goitregen it's things that cause a
goiter okay now what is a goiter
basically a goiter is an enlarged
thyroid gland and the thyroid gland is
right at the bottom of your neck about
two and a half inches wide so when that
thing starts swelling up that's called
the goiter and there are foods that
cause that and those are the foods that
you need to avoid because what they do
is they interfere with certain enzymes
and they stimulate certain enzymes and
they increase certain other hormones
like they increase the thyroid
stimulating hormone which comes down
from the pituitary and then it makes the
thyroid actually get bigger so there are
many different
aspects to what a goiter can do for the
thyroid but I'm just going to make you
aware of what these goiter foods are
specifically all right number one
cassava okay cassava is a goitrogenic
food number two lima beans number three
sorghum okay which is a type of grain
number four sweet potato number five
flaxseed number six
cruciferous vegetables and that would
include broccoli kale brussels sprouts
cabbage radish Watercress bok choy
cauliflower horseradish and arugula but
you do want to avoid consuming a lot of
cruciferous but if you're consuming like
small amounts like less than five ounces
you're not going to have a problem okay
I'm talking about large amounts and even
if you do have cruciferous if you cook
them or steam them or ferment them as in
sauerkraut you're going to reduce the
amount of this effect and also if you
have a little c-calp that will also help
as well I mean if you look at the
research you would have to consume a
good amount of this over a period of
time to create a goiter I'm just
bringing up all the foods because you
may be consuming a lot of these Foods
maybe not individually in large amounts
but across the board another one is a
grain called Millet the next big one is
soy tofu soy milk especially soy protein
isolates any soy now the next one might
surprise you but onions are the food
that have the most quercetin and
quercetin can give you a goitrogenic
effect so if you have a goiter you
probably should be careful about
consuming too many onions now this last
thing I'm going to talk about isn't
classically
you know considered a uh goitrogen but
it definitely destroys the thyroid
especially the autoimmune thyroid
Hashimoto's in fact ninety percent of
all hypothyroid cases are Hashimoto's
and the biggest culprit is this gluten
okay in grains a lot of different grains
so gluten is something you have to avoid
now the question is why this is related
to an area called molecular mimicry if
you have antibodies to gluten which a
lot of people do those antibodies can
cross over and start to attack the
thyroid because of this molecular
similarity now when dealing with the
thyroid you would also want to avoid
anything that depletes selenium iodine
iron
and vitamin A these are key nutrients
that you want sufficient amounts so to
get enough iodine and selenium that
would be all the seafood that would be
also the sea cow Brazil nuts and also
you can get both of these if you do sea
salt of course iron is pretty easy to
get if you're doing like red meat or
animal products and vitamin A you can
get that from egg yolks butter cod liver
oil beef liver things like that now that
I talked about what foods to avoid let's
talk about what you should eat and for
that check this video out